Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I'm sorry for being a little late today.
My manager was like, we have to talk about the sponsors and business stuff.
And then, like, because, like, basically, I was off the grid for two days.
So, I was off the grid for two days.
And so, no, I'm not blaming my manager.
It was partially my fault.
So, I did not exist on the internet for the last two days because I was basically outside, like, doing stuff.
Yeah, so, because I was off the grid, there was a lot of things I needed to catch up on.
And, like, you know, because I was about to start stream, my manager was like, this is the only time I can actually talk to you because you're actually online.
So, there's going to be, like, a couple of sponsors lined up for the next... well, not this month.
I think it'll be, like, next month or some shit.
And I said yes to a bunch of stuff because, like, daddy needs money to pay her debt collectors.
I'm not in debt.
I didn't borrow money from the mafia.
I just... I need to... I need to fill up my bank account after what happened from the concert.
Hey, after the concert, my bank account is looking a little less empty.
So, I got to fill it up right now.
So, I was saying yes to a bunch of stuff.
I was like, oh, yeah, I'll do that.
And I'll do that.
And I'll do that, too.
So, yeah, so...
August might be... look, okay.
I love, like, the comparison because my manager is like, I don't want to make you look like a race car.
So, like, please choose the ones you really want to do.
Because we're not going to make you into a fucking race car.
Where, you know, like, those, like, Formula One race cars where it's all just sponsors plastered all over the car itself?
No, I can't...
Ka-chow!
So, I'm trying to make sure I don't end up like that.
Because, like, I say yes very easily to things.
And sometimes I undercharge myself because I was like, oh, I really want to do this sponsor.
Like, fuck it.
They want to charge...
Okay, there was one where I was like, I'll do it for X amount of money.
That's fine.
Like, they're like, okay.
Um, my manager was like, oh, so this sponsor wants you to do, um...
He paid this amount.
Are you okay with that?
And I was like, yeah, I'm fine with that.
And then he was like, okay, I'll ask for 1k more.
Papa Smear, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How much should I put my logo on?
You're just checking your rates.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, um, but yeah.
Anyway, I have a lot of dad updates today.
But I'm gonna, um, I'm gonna stagger these stories.
Because a lot of stuff happened for dad.
Um, because I was outside, like, touching grass.
I actually took him to a park yesterday, too.
Um, there was, like, those, like, horse car- Like, those, like, horse rides and stuff.
Where, like, you sit on, like, back of the horse- Like, not on the horse, but, like, you know, like, this, like, little, um, carriage thing.
And then, like, I sat there in the back with dad.
And, like, he was just super chill like that.
He was just super chill.
He's like, ah, yes.
Pull me bigger.
You bigger dogs.
Being pulled by these big-ass dogs.
Yes.
Pull me.
I am rich.
And you are just a peasant in my eyes.
Anyway, he's just a chill guy.
Okay, by the way, um, he- Okay, he's such a little shit.
Okay, so, the last two days, you know, it's because I'm, like, off the grid.
And I wasn't existing online.
Um, he- and was just, like, mostly relaxing.
He let me sleep.
He actually let me sleep and didn't demand me to feed him early.
Or, like, uh, or, uh, like, for walkies or anything.
So, like, I was able to wake up at times I want to wake up.
So, you know, usually he would demand me, uh, to feed him at, like, 5 a.m.
or 6 a.m.
But, for once in my life, he actually, like, um, didn't do that.
Like, the last two days.
The last two days.
So generous of him, I know.
Uh, and I was like, oh, that's so nice.
During my, like, you know, break days, too.
Like, my rest days.
He's not gonna, like, fuck me over.
And then, you know, today, we're- Um, I actually officially go back to work.
Uh, guess who decided to wake me up at 5 20 a.m.
today in the morning?
He's like, he's like, oh, you're going back to work?
Guess I have to go back to work, too.
So, he's like, he's here.
He's just trying to make sure I get there on time, you know?
Even though I work at home.
Um, he's like, you know what?
Break time's over.
I was like, please.
Please, it's 5 20 a.m.
And I was like, I'm gonna sleep.
I'm gonna go back to sleep.
Maybe he'll get tired.
And then he wakes me up again at fucking 6 30 in the morning.
He's like, the snooze button only lasts for an hour.
And he's like, oh, it's time!
What?
I want food!
Oh, that's so considerate of him.
I know, I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
How did you know?
How did you know I'm going back to work today?
How?
Why?
He gave me a false sense of security.
I was like, oh my god, I fixed him.
I legitimately was like, oh my god, is this it?
Did I finally fix him?
Is he not gonna wake me up at god-awful hours for food?
It was all a bait.
He baited me so hard.
Anyway, okay, so, um, when I took him to a park, I actually took him to a real park, not just a dog park, but an actual park park.
Not only did we do, like, those, like, horse carriage rides, um, but there was, like, a giant-ass fucking field.
And so, you know, obviously, I want him, I want to play fetch with him.
And, um, and then, it was very sunny outside.
It was actually, like, incredibly sunny, too.
And, um, and, like, I chucked the ball really fucking far.
Like, you know, because it was a large-ass field.
I was like, go get it, Dad!
Look at that!
Now you can run to your heart's content.
He ran to the ball, and then he gave up halfway, and then pivoted to the shade.
And I was just like, are you fucking kidding me?
I literally was like, yeah!
And then halfway there, he, like, he, like, this sharp turn to the left, and then went to the shade.
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
You love playing fetch!
And the one time, the one time we actually have the field of your dreams, and you were like, no!
Running's too hard!
Like, why did you throw that fire?
Okay, don't worry.
I'll give you guys a diagram.
I'll draw you guys a little picture of, like, this little shit.
And he's like...
And then there, and it was like, the shade was just a bunch of benches, and he, he sat, and then he just laid down there, and, and, like, underneath the bench.
And I'm like, are you serious?
Okay, don't worry.
I got, I got a picture.
Uh, I don't know how hot it was pretty.
It was just really sunny.
I don't even know how hot it was.
Um, but it was just incredibly sunny.
Okay, so this was the diagram.
I'll draw you.
Alright, here it is.
This is what, this is what he was doing.
It was like, nope!
Like, he can't, he ran there.
He did go there.
He was going that direction, and then he's just like, boop.
Um, Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I love the short time program channel.
Since I can't always catch the stream, the data updates are always so funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hard left.
He's like, oh, I could get the ball, or I could go, I could go over to the left side with a shade.
I was like, that's enough exercise for the day now.
I was like, what exercise?
You were just sitting, you were just lying down at the horse carriage.
What do you mean, exercise?
You would be a lazy fucking dog being pulled by bigger animals.
Oh, he's so spoiled now.
He's so fucking spoiled.
He touched the grass.
Yes, that is enough exercise.
Also, another dad update.
When I was at my usual dog park, I think last night, he would not leave this couple alone.
And I was so confused because I was like, please poop.
That's all I want from you.
I was like, please, dad, please poop.
And then all he did was just like hover around this couple.
And then I gave up, by the way.
Like, I just ended up going home because I was like, I'm not going to stay here for an hour waiting for you to poop.
And then the couple was like, oh, I'm sorry.
We gave him treats.
Like, we were the ones that gave him treats last month.
And he thinks we still have them.
And I was like, you little shit.
Like, it has been a month since you've seen this couple.
And I can't believe he remembers.
He, he, I was like, he, he never forgets.
He, he, he never forgets your face if you give him a treat.
Because I don't even remember.
I was so confused.
And he's like, they're like, yeah, yeah.
We gave him treats last month.
Remember?
Like, when we, when we saw you last time.
I was like, I do not remember.
I was like, you are not that, I'm sorry.
This shows me.
I was like, you are not that important in my life to remember this.
But they were very important in dad's life.
Anyway, so.
That's why he was like, covering them.
He was like, oh my God.
It's them.
It's been a month.
Oh my God.
You've returned the messiahs.
The treat givers.
I'll always be grateful for your generosity.
They made, they made an impact in his life right there.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Freedom.
EP time.
Oh, Rodrigo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You gave dad treats.
Dad will remember that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They are like, not even top 10.
They're like, top, top three people in his life, life right now.
All right.
Anyway, game time.
Alright, today we're gonna be playing Dragoon Drop.
For those who are wondering what game this is, basically, a bunch of dragoons got together and made me a game for my birthday.
And it's basically like, if you ever play the Suica game, the watermelon game, it's basically like that.
But instead of like fruits and watermelon, it's me and dragoons.
So yeah, that's basically what, I mean, that's basically self-explanatory.
That's what this game is about.
So I'm super excited to try this game out.
I had an insane, unhealthy addiction to the Suica game, but like, not playing it.
I had an unhealthy obsession watching Suica game for some reason.
I was like living vicariously off of other people playing the game.
Because it was just so addicting to watch for some reason.
But I didn't play that much myself because I just liked watching people play it more.
But I like, I never really got, I don't, I don't even remember if I got, I don't know, did I ever got watermelon?
I don't even remember if I got Suica.
I think I did.
I was just, I think I did.
But I never got double watermelon.
But yeah, no, it's, it's been so long.
But yes, this is basically the game.
You can try out the game yourself.
I put the download link in the description.
And there's apparently a live leaderboard too.
So you can compete with other dragoons in the water, sorry, not the water, in Dragoon Drop.
But yes, you can also compete as well against your own fellow dragoons to see who is the best dragoon dropper.
Other things I want to talk about, oh yes, for the Doki merch stuff, for those who don't know, I have released some birthday merch and also a lot of other merch launches on the website.
I asked them about like whether or not there's any limited pre-orders yet.
And they said at this current moment, there isn't.
But I will update you if they do plan on adding like, um, like anything that's like limited on the store.
But I'll let you guys know.
For now, I have not heard anything yet.
Devin, thank you, Magenta Super!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy B-Day, thank you!
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you, everyone, for celebrating my birthday with me.
On, uh, was it Saturday or Friday?
Wait, no, was it?
No, it was not Saturday.
It was Friday.
Thank you, everyone, for celebrating my birthday with me on Friday!
Um, it was such a great day.
I was honestly, you guys could tell I sort of like hibernated after that.
Because I didn't tweet anything.
I didn't tweet anything at all about my birthday stuff.
I didn't tweet anything after all the stuff was done.
I just disappeared.
Other than my mandatory sponsors.
By the way, speaking of sponsors, tonight I will be doing another two-hour...
The last two-hour sponsor of Mechabrick tonight on Twitch.
So you guys can check me out there.
Later on after Dragoon Drop.
So yeah.
And so it will be another two hours.
I'm going to do more custom lobbies too.
So you guys want to have more chance to play with me in Mechabrick.
Make sure to download the game.
So we can do some more custom lobbies later.
Alright, anyway, let's actually run Dragoon Drop.
Alright, Main Wave Unity.
Oh, I forgot.
You guys can't hear it.
You guys are supposed to be like, what is...
Why is she...
Why is she saying that?
I forgot this is a Chrome tab.
Not a fucking game tab.
I was like...
I sound like a fucking schizo right now.
Listening to the voices in my head.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let me make sure I have everything.
I just want to fix the...
I'm just trying to fix this real.
Fix the...
There we go.
Okay.
That should be good.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Let me know if the music is loud enough or...
Alright.
So...
We're trying to make a Suica.
Which is...
Uh...
Which is me.
I am...
I am the Dragoon.
I am the peak Dragoon life form.
Uh...
To be fair, I don't think in this game.
But you have to think.
Because you're supposed to...
Oh yeah, by the way.
Here's the global leaderboard.
So...
Um...
Guys, you think I can make it?
I know.
I'm like...
Whoa!
When...
Why did...
Why did mom let you have two leaderboard slots?
Uh...
The final evolution of Dragoons is basically me.
Um...
But I legitimately...
Okay.
I'll let you guys know this right now.
I don't think when I play this game, these types of games, I legitimately just...
I just drop things and then hope for the best.
So like, if...
If I get lucky, I get lucky.
I...
I have...
I don't do any strategies for this.
I know like...
That's not how you're supposed to play the game.
But like...
My...
My brain cannot fit more things right now.
There's very...
Very limited...
I'm playing for the vibes.
Exactly.
There's very limited hard drive space.
Um...
Not SSD by the way.
I don't have...
Oh, hey, look!
It's Kroki!
Um...
My brain cannot afford an SSD.
So like...
It's just a hard drive.
That's even...
I know it's even worse.
Uh...
HD hard drive brain.
Drop good.
Yeah, as long as I drop good, I win.
I did do a test run of this like...
Last night.
And I think I got to...
I got to like...
Um...
I think like...
800.
And then like...
I didn't lose.
I just got bored and just...
Started playing things everywhere.
And...
Doki brain is a floppy drive.
Dango!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
No!
And literally I was like...
Ah, 800.
That's good enough.
And I just started...
Like left clicking.
Ha ha ha ha!
In the center.
Ah ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
I was like...
Okay, that's enough testing now.
Yeah!
Uh...
I guess I'll put him here.
And then...
I'll put this guy here.
Ba dum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum...
Ba dum...
Okay, we'll make another tomato.
Okay, I fucked it up already.
But that's okay.
Okay, I can fix this.
I can fix her.
Okay, um... Some things in life is just not fixable, and you just gotta accept it.
Oh, how did I fuck it up already?
Oh, no, I didn't.
Look at that!
Baited.
I knew I didn't fuck up.
Oh, who said it was over?
You guys were non-believers.
I knew it wasn't over.
It was all planned.
It's the reaction time.
Oh, wait.
Oh, fuck.
Maybe I can, like, push him over?
Maybe?
Oh, why did I do that?
Oh, it's a rat.
What's the rat?
What does the rat do?
What the fuck does the rat do?
What does it do?
Is it just there?
Is it just, like, a cock blocker?
What was his purpose?
Oh, they're never gonna meet.
That's so sad.
They're never... What the rat doing?
Is it just, like, there to fuck with me?
It's so sad.
These two whores are never gonna meet up.
There's, like, Jesus in between them.
You know, like, when you're slow dancing in, like, middle school and up?
They'll be like, make sure you have Jesus in front of... Like, leave enough room for Jesus.
That's what I'm doing right now.
These sluts will never touch.
If you're gonna show your butthead.
Jesus.
God, leave room for Jesus.
Gee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I associated crows with you so much.
Last week, another VTuber was playing just crow things.
And I thought you were collabing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Leave room if you wanna be forgiven.
I still can't believe Pom Pomper in one fucking whore.
That's the only reason why he won.
And you guys know it.
He showed his asshole.
To so many people.
Sinamaru deserves that win.
He was robbed!
I'm not coping.
I am not coping.
Like, if he didn't show his booty hole...
Sinamaru would have won.
Sinamaru is cultured.
He don't need to show his booty hole...
...to win five times in a row.
Just respect the asshole.
Okay, nice.
He's...
Yeah!
He's not!
P.R.S.
No!
Yes, he does.
Sinamaru needs to win another year in a row.
That's why he's my kamioshi.
I actually...
Before Pom Pomperin became, like, super fucking popular...
Um...
I actually own a Pom Pomperin onesie.
That shows his booty hole.
Only Rose sells as...
As usual.
Luca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He showed whole...
We respond.
What surprised me the most was...
Where the fuck did Pochaco even come from?
When did he be...
When did he became popular?
Like...
Who allowed him...
To be top three?
Yeah, he was a dark horse.
He worked hard.
I swear, I've never seen anything with Pochaco before.
I was like...
How the fuck did he even came third place?
I see more shit with...
I don't even...
Okay, okay.
So, I don't know if you guys know this.
But, like...
Uh...
No, fuck my Melody.
She has something to hide.
I hate my Melody.
Uh...
But, like...
I swear to God.
Okay, so, like...
For those who don't know, like...
Uh...
Sanrio lore...
Um...
Each character...
Has, like...
Not...
Not each of them, but...
Actually, no.
Majority of the characters...
Have, uh...
Their own YouTube channel...
And, like, social media platform.
And...
Take it back!
No!
I won't!
I know she's hiding something!
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, and they actually do song covers and stuff, too.
So...
Um...
So, like...
A lot of their YouTube channels...
You can find, like...
You know, like...
Hello Kitty will have, like...
Her own...
Oh my God!
They're gonna touch...
Leave room for Jesus!
Ha ha ha!
But...
Um...
They would have, like...
Uh...
Song covers...
That...
Oh my God!
Suica!
Ha ha ha ha!
Planned!
I did not...
Definitely planned!
Ha ha ha!
In...
Jokey!
Ha ha ha!
Anyway...
Um...
In...
Uh...
For San Nuyo...
So, like...
Each character will have the...
Their own, like...
Um...
Music videos and stuff for, like...
They will do cover songs and everything.
And also produce original songs and stuff, too.
And I'm like...
Where the...
If you look at all their channels...
I swear to God...
Like...
I have never seen any content...
I'm pretty sure he does upload content...
But I...
Personally...
Have never seen any of Pochaco's content...
Going viral!
Like...
Karomi!
Or...
Sinamaru!
Or even...
Pom Pom...
I would even give it to that...
That Pom Pom Paren...
Had some viral cover songs...
And original songs...
But I swear to God...
I have not heard of any original song...
From goddamn fucking Pochaco!
Like...
Karomi...
Karomi got fourth...
But she has...
Greedy, greedy...
Where is Pochaco?
Yeah, she...
Pochaco's an industry plan...
I swear to God...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha...
What's that voice?
That's the voice of justice...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
It's not all about the song...
What is it?
What is Pochaco's charm point?
He even wears clothes...
Ha ha ha...
He's ashamed of his own body...
Ha ha ha ha...
It's just third place...
Yeah!
And he stole third place...
From Karomi!
You're the dog baby...
As in the industry...
Yeah!
And it took him how many years...
To even get third place...
Uh...
You...
Wait...
Ha ha ha ha...
Stay mad...
Yeah!
You and like...
The two other Pochaco fans...
Um...
Recount!
I demand a recount!
I bet you...
I bet you those...
But votes were bought in too...
I...
The Pochaco votes are bought in...
Send out Karomi fans...
But never...
We are too respectful...
They done my boy Pochaco bad...
Ha ha ha ha...
True!
Ha ha ha...
Haters will say it was fake...
I demand a recount!
Ha ha ha...
For my boy Karomi...
Okay, Batsumaru does not deserve more...
Ha ha ha...
Batsumaru should stay losing...
Not gonna lie...
Ha ha ha...
Uh...
Um...
Okay, I think I'm gonna lose this...
Cause I have no idea what I'm doing right now...
Ha ha ha...
Ba da da da...
But he used to be popular...
In what world?
Oh my god...
I think it's over, guys...
You know what?
For a first attempt...
That's pretty...
That's pretty good for a first attempt...
Not gonna lie...
Ba da da...
Ba da...
But I didn't think I'd get this far...
To lay...
Good job...
Oh my god...
You stupid rat...
Good job, Doki...
Um...
Surfing Burb...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
Kroki came in today...
She's so soft and level...
And fits with my other fellow Burbs...
Thank you again, Doki...
Thank you for the super chat...
Uh...
Burb...
Thank you, thank you...
Uh...
Michi...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
Oh, wait, what?
How did I die?
Okay, you know what?
That's fine...
I'll upload my score...
I don't know what it does when I press Upload Score.
So, Upload Score.
Real Doki.
Alright.
Where am I?
Where do I see my leader?
I wanna know.
Where am I?
Okay.
That's pretty good for it.
2,460?
I think that's pretty good.
Oh my gosh, I wanna tell you guys a really cute story.
During my meet and greet at Anime Expo...
By the way, I did a meet and greet at my booth.
Um, and... Oh my gosh, so...
Um...
Apparently...
Uh...
There was a...
There was a little girl.
But she...
We were just about to end the meet and greet.
And...
My staff member that was running the meet and greet was like, Oh, stop!
Um...
Wait, wait, wait, stay, stay, stay!
We have one more.
Um, like...
Cause, like, she, like...
Basically, this little girl, like, literally ran over because she was late.
And...
Um...
And she, like, ran over to, like, make it in time for my meet and greet.
Just literally...
I was about to go.
I was like, alright guys, bye!
And then a staff member stopped me and was like, Wait, wait, wait, we have one more!
And...
She was like...
Quiet!
She had, like, tears in her eyes cause she thought she was gonna miss it.
And...
Um...
And she was, like, super happy and was like, Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I made it.
And...
Um...
My staff member told me after the meet and greet was over, Um...
She was telling me that...
Um...
That girl stayed around the booth for one hour.
Trying to raise money and asking her friends and stuff.
And, like, family members for, like...
Like...
To pool together...
Five dollars to buy a sticker to enter the lottery.
Uh...
For the meet and greet.
And I was like, Oh my god!
That is...
Like...
So sweet.
I was like...
Like...
That...
That she spent, like, an entire hour.
So she can, like, just get one sticker.
Because she really wanted to meet me.
And...
Um...
And I was like...
It was really sweet that my staff member, like...
Um...
You know...
Uh...
Let her have a chance to, like, meet me and stuff.
Like, added her into the...
Uh...
No, she was apparently actually a little girl.
Um...
I could tell that she was, like...
Really young and stuff.
And it was like...
It was so cute.
I was like...
Oh my god.
So sweet.
Like...
And she's like...
Oh my god.
I really love your content.
And you make me laugh and everything.
I was like...
Oh, thank you.
Don't cry.
So I was like...
Her Oshii's a demon.
What the fuck?
She's not so sweet.
If she's your...
If you're her Oshii.
True.
A sweet girl.
But yet, this is her Oshii.
Uh...
This kid...
Um...
The kid loves...
Roblox and bounty hunter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why did you make her pay?
Huh?
What do you mean me?
I wasn't even...
I wasn't even at my boof right...
Am I even running my own boof, guys?
I was...
She never had a chance.
I hope she never played Roblox again.
Oh yeah.
When we're cyberbullying children.
Be like...
Leave.
Guys.
I did not do what Chibi Dookie did.
When she was like...
I'm gonna shoot you.
I was like...
What the fuck?
I didn't...
I just said...
Leave.
Get out.
That's all I said.
I...
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Give her money back.
That poor girl.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Bro.
Uh hum.
Um...
But yeah.
No.
I thought that was...
Incredibly sweet though.
Um...
That we...
Let her...
You know...
That I ended up having a meet and greet with her.
Um...
And everything.
Oh, she said she said the quiet part out loud.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna... I think the first try was as good as it's gonna get.
I don't think I'm gonna get better score than that.
But, um... Canonical egg goon.
I don't think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, I'll tweet the picture later.
But the first thing I ate out of the cake was I literally just bit off the head of the long goon.
And then I just put it back in the fridge.
I ate more of the cake after that, though.
But, like, the first thing I ate from that cake was literally the head of the long goon.
And I was like, that's good enough.
As he deserves.
Devon, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um...
Of course, of course it's the long goon.
He needs to be punished for his crimes.
Ba-da-da-dum.
Ba-da-dum.
Oh, my god.
You'll never be able to touch.
That's right.
I'm gonna Romeo and Juliet you.
You'll never be able to meet your true love.
Yeah, get married first.
Just no touching until marriage.
Doomed Yuri.
Could be Doomed Yowie, you don't know that.
Oh my gosh though, but seeing all the concerts that were happening throughout the Anime Expo week.
Luca, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Dookie brings cyberbullets children and makes little girls cry after 4-seer to gamble more at 5 p.m.
Fake news!
I don't talk to people who spread fake news.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Dibs, I'm the long goon, Dookie8.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, but like, it's very inspiring to see like all the, uh, the amazing concerts that were going on during, um, Anime Expo.
Um, um, I, I, I definitely would love to do something.
Oh, hey!
Grenade!
Wait, I don't even know where to put it, to be fair.
Maybe like, here?
Fire in the hole!
Okay.
Okay, that did nothing.
Okay, I, I tricked him more, but that's okay.
Sometimes, sometimes it's okay to be disappointed.
Sometimes, that's, that's fine.
Life is meant to be disappointing.
Wait, what?
Oh, fuck, she's gone.
Just like that.
She's gone.
She fucking disappeared.
It's like a ghost.
Alright, this time.
Wait, what happened to my grenade?
Oh my god, okay.
It's like, my grenade, it just disappeared.
What happened to it?
Minto jumpscare.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Oh my god, it's Minto.
Yeah, I would love to do more concerts in the future.
Um, I don't know.
I never really...
I, I don't...
Uh...
Because like, you know...
Uh, usually those invitations go towards like, the singers.
Oh shit, that's where you'll never touch.
You'll never touch.
I'm literally...
I have four squares.
I just need one more.
Um...
Yeah, I don't see myself as an actual singer-singer, though.
Uh, but it would be amazing to be invited to do, like, an actual concert setting.
Because mine was, like, at Anime Expo, but it was more geared towards, like...
I feel like it was more like a showcase versus, like, an actual concert setting, where, you know...
Um, like, uh...
Why are they showing their hoes?
Because they're whores.
They saw what Pom Pom Perrin did, and thought this was all they have to do now.
So, yeah, I'm going to totally... Pom Pom Perrin is a bad example to the children.
He's a bad role model!
Oh my god, dead!
Whoa!
But yeah, I'm just... I'm happy to give you guys a free concert, though.
I'm happy, but yeah, I would love to.
It was such a great...
Oh my god, he's so chonky.
If he does become that chonky, I...
Like, I...
Um, he is definitely going to go on a diet or get something.
I would never want a wiener dog to be that chonky.
But yeah, I'd love to be...
Uh, I want to, you know, like...
Also, like, I don't know, I was, like, thinking about it.
I think if I ever do, like, another...
If I want to do a giant-ass project, like, the next...
Um...
I guess, like, level of organizing I want to do...
But, okay, it's very hard.
I know concert organization is very, very hard.
Because, like...
You know, like, the Phantom Thief shit?
That was more so, like...
We just show up, and we just show up, sing, and dance.
So, like, we don't have to do, like, the actual, like...
Organizing and the planning of anything, like Min and I.
Um...
But, like, the one thing I really...
Want to do...
Is have a concert.
Like, an actual concert venue and everything.
Um...
Is, like...
At, like...
Uh...
In, like, I...
In Asia and Europe.
And Canada.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
America has it too good!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I think it'd be cool.
I think it'd be cool to have, like, a little world tour of stuff.
With, like, Indies and everything.
Um...
But, like I said, I...
Like...
It can't be free.
Ha ha ha ha!
Which sucks.
Um...
That's the one thing that...
I mean, it can be.
If, like...
Regarding, like...
Uh...
Oh...
You're slowly going down.
You're slowly going lower and lower and lower.
Yeah, cause, like...
Patch...
Like, I told you guys how much it actually costs to make my free.
Concert.
And that's why, like...
Um...
By the way, like...
Min and I, we made...
I would say we made a lot.
From, like, merch sales and concert tickets.
Um...
And even then, like...
That was after the profit split with the organizers, too.
So, like...
Um...
It is, like, money-wise.
Like, that's why people do concerts and stuff.
I don't know if you guys know this.
Uh...
But, um...
Well, for me, it was a lot.
I don't know.
For, I guess, like, other performers, it might not be considered a lot.
But I thought it was a lot.
Uh...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
But if you guys didn't know, uh...
Uh...
For, like...
For musicians and performers...
Um...
The b- The most they make...
The money...
The mo- Uh...
Uh...
Sorry, I can't fucking talk.
But, um, the most they earn from, like, the sources of income they get the most out of is from concerts and merch.
That's, uh, literally, like, uh, they make money from the merch and the concerts themselves.
So, like, to be fair, though, I spent a lot of money, because, like, in general, on, like, dance lessons.
And, uh, dance lessons, as well as, uh, uh, you know, prepping for the concert and, like, traveling as well.
And stuff like that.
So, like, you know, um, but I still made quite a good amount from the Phantom Thief stuff.
Um, I feel like if I ever want to plan something where I want to do another concert for, like, maybe, like, an indie concert thing.
Um...
I'd love to have it hosted and either, like, you know, cat, like, maybe, like, a tour thing.
Oh, that would be so cool.
Like an, an indie tour.
But, like, I don't know, I think the only way to get invited for something like that is to, like, make it my own.
Because I don't think I'd get invited.
I don't think, I don't think I'd, I'd get invited since I'm not really a singer.
And they, like, they'll invite the actual singers if they want to make an indie concert.
And they...
Like, an indie concert with, like, you know, merch and, like, venue and stuff.
I feel like the only way I can get invited is if I have to make it myself.
Um...
Never say never?
I don't know.
I just feel like, I mean, like, if they want to sell seats and stuff, it makes sense though.
You want someone that can sing.
And I just, like, I literally shitpost.
I still want to do, like, variety shows and stuff too.
Like, not just, like...
Like, okay, when I...
I'm planning, guys, by the way...
Uh...
By the way, I'm already, like...
Ever since...
After the concert was over...
Um...
After the concert was over, like, today, this morning, I was talking to the production team.
And...
Uh...
We're planning on...
Um...
I'm starting my plans right now.
With...
Uh...
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
With them regarding, like, an official 3D debut.
And stuff.
So, like, you know, there'll be, like, variety stuff and things.
Like, what you see in a normal 3D debut.
But yeah, I'm starting plans with them right now.
And, like, discussing what I want to do.
But yeah.
I'm super excited.
I can finally...
After the debut, I can finally use my...
3D model normally.
I can actually use my 3D model right after.
Oh, shit.
I was not paying attention.
I...
I was...
I think this might be my worst run.
Oh, shit.
Hey, mint.
Wait, what was...
Oh, wait.
Booty hole.
I was like, wait, what is she though?
I forgot what dragoon that's supposed to be.
Um...
You filled 1,800 person call to capacity.
You can still...
Oh, thank you, Nexi.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah, but...
It was also free, though.
It was a free concept.
Uh...
Taste.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Thanks for playing our game.
Sorry if the grenade is bugged.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you for making this game.
I really appreciate it.
I love...
I always love like...
Oh my gosh.
Also like...
I'm actually...
I love...
I love like...
How creative people can get.
Especially like the mini games and stuff that you guys make.
Um...
So I really appreciate it.
You guys made this for free for me.
Thank you.
Um...
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
It's...
Dookie Bird.
Can't believe I won that 50-50 for the meet and greet.
Also...
Uh...
Please let super...
No.
Never.
I'll never let them touch.
Haha.
It's a sin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
JP.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe I see Watake at a concert.
I was all over the moon when I heard it.
Uh...
Unfortunately, security told us to sit down at first.
But for whatever reason, Lily let us back up.
Great performance.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh yeah.
So I saw someone...
Uh...
Um...
I saw someone mentioned...
That...
Um...
About my surprise appearance in...
Uh...
The...
Virtual vacation...
Um...
On Doobie Song.
And...
Yeah!
Now you know why I was so fucking busy all the time.
Uh...
Someone asked- Okay.
I want you guys to know...
Who are that song specifically?
I think Min and I were both in a similar situation.
Like...
Uh...
Min literally...
We were like...
Both traveling around that time.
When...
Um...
We were...
As to...
When like...
We were asked to like...
Record it.
And so we're like, oh, fuck.
So literally, the day we came back from our travels, because we were both traveling for our own concerts that we're doing, like, you know, her, for her.
We were all, like, traveling to prepare and stuff and record for, like, because she has, like, several appearances in 3D.
And I was trying to, like, you know, practice for, like, my concert and stuff like that and preparing for my concert.
So, um, we're like, we got time.
And literally, when we had to record for it, for the backings of Home... Oh, goodbye, little egg.
When, um... We had one day... Well, I had one day to record it before the deadline.
Like, I literally just got back from... From traveling.
And... And... I learned... I learned... I learned the song in two hours, and then I hit record.
And then...
And then I sent it over.
I... I was like, I'm sorry.
Clutch.
Clutch as fuck.
You guys can't tell, though.
You guys couldn't tell I recorded that in a day within two hours.
Uh... And it took me another two hours to finish recording it.
Uh... Bro...
Whoa!
Look at that chonky boy.
Let's see.
Geo!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Doki, we are asking for... We are asking for paid streaming when the concert dropped.
I'm pretty sure lots of people would go and watch your concert!
Ah!
Thank you, Geo!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I don't know.
The hard part for that is just to find, like...
I'm pretty sure, like... I have no idea how that works.
Like, the paid streaming shit.
Like...
I think you need, like, to set up a contract with some... Like, a fucking...
Like, company that does that shit.
And then... Oh my god.
A lot of logistics.
I don't know anything about it, though.
Um...
But yeah, that's, like, something...
I don't know.
I...
I would love to do it again in the future.
Cause it was fun!
It was really fun.
And it was fun seeing, like...
Uh...
Seeing all the people, like, you know...
Um...
Cheering and, like...
Cheering for the Oshi and everything.
It's always such a...
Like, a fun scene.
Like...
Just, like, fun to see in the clips and stuff.
Uh...
Next scene, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I know people who flew in and got hotels to see your concert.
Not necessarily free!
Thank you again for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you again!
I really appreciate everybody that came to Anime Expo.
And, um...
To watch the concert and had a lot of fun.
I really appreciate it.
Oh yeah!
For the polished version...
Of...
I don't know what to do with this grenade.
Like...
I...
I don't know.
But, for the polished version of the concert...
Um...
I'm also in talks with them right now.
And...
They're gonna give me the timeline...
On when it'll be done.
Um...
So...
I hope it won't be that long.
I hope it'll be like...
One to two months.
But I did...
I will add an encore.
I'm gonna add...
Um...
An encore...
I know I said like...
Maybe two songs.
But I'm just gonna add...
One song...
Um...
As an encore.
Uh...
Just so we can have...
The polished version earlier.
Cause I'm worried if I do two...
It's gonna take longer.
No, I haven't decided yet.
I don't know what's starting to do.
I don't know.
I'm not sure yet.
Uh...
Luke, I thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Proceeds to perform in several concerts.
Um...
It's not several.
Actually...
It was...
Uh...
Two.
Um...
Actually...
Uh...
It was just two...
Orca.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
So, so, so, so much...
Jokey for holding out for our meeting.
Green on Sunday.
Despite your busy schedule.
It meant the world to me.
Split the super between you...
Her...
And her.
As her agent.
Thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah.
So what Orca is saying is that...
Uh...
They...
Overslept...
Uh...
They overslept from my meet and greet.
They...
Didn't set up an alarm and overslept the meet and greet.
And then...
Um...
And then I...
Out of the...
Goodness of my own heart...
Say...
Uh...
Never say I'm...
I never...
Never say I'm not a good person.
Um...
Out of the goodness of my own heart...
Say...
Uh...
Came back...
An hour later...
To finish my meet and greet.
I'm so kind and humble, guys.
So humble.
Uh...
Let's see.
However...
Can't be true.
Uh...
Oh my god.
Can the code...
The cookies cannot touch.
Cos then it'd be a murder.
Uh...
Yeah, um, you would be fine.
Alright, touch.
Nice, dracoons can touch, though.
I don't mind if the goons touch.
Oh my god, not the rat.
But if the croquis touch, then the world will end.
Hon!
Well, uh, thank you for that one gifted chip.
Thank you, thank you.
Ba-da-da-dum.
Ba-da-dum-bum.
Maybe I can make him touch here.
I'll force it.
I want the dragon winch to touch, though.
That's fine.
Um.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Upcoming pay stream plus membership equals easy money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, that's true.
I can make that membership.
But then, like, ah, I guess, like, membership chip.
Ah, no, because then, like, you know, if it's, like, an indie concert, I want to be able to...
What?
What happened to my grenade?
Oh, I keep forgetting!
The grenade merges into the dragoon.
Um, but then, like, you know, if I'm doing an indie concert with other indies, um, I'd want to, like, split the profits.
Obviously, split the profits with them.
Um, Fuzzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Double tapping my member with a thank you for the concert.
And thanks for continuing to be our favorite giggle bird!
From an old-ass otaku ojisan.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for letting me hold the chest toggle at the meet and greet.
Um, also, could I get a happy birthday?
Mine was literally right after yours.
And it was super busy.
Of course, Manny.
Oh my gosh, he's so greedy.
This is the greed in the Bible, Manny.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Manny.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Your green seconds, Manny.
Um...
Charco!
I think we're gonna lose this, by the way.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki finding out she is a singer.
It's like Hagrid telling Harry that he is a wizard.
This is a compliment, by the way.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Oh, he's dead.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm never gonna get my peek.
I'm never... I don't even know how.
It just literally just happened.
I'll never know how it happened.
I'm just naturally gifted.
What can I say?
Okay.
And then this will turn into a giant goon.
A chonky goon.
Oh my god.
Already another grenade?
I don't expect a grenade that fast.
Oh yeah, by the way, I know I keep talking, like, everyone's, like, super hyped that I'm thinking about, like, organizing something like that.
That's not gonna happen for a very long time, sorry.
I need... I need rest.
I still cry.
If I actually ever try anything like that, I cannot.
I'm tired.
I'm... I'm so tired.
Yes.
Guys, I'm so tired.
My brain has been, like, I swear to God, I feel like I've been, like, brain rotted.
After.
But will it happen eventually?
I don't know.
I definitely need sponsors for that.
Let's see.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Continuing the birthday change.
My birthday today.
Can I also get a happy birthday?
Of course, Marshall.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Marshall.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Marshall.
We have a great birthday.
This is like the one time you'll get your super chats read.
Like, in a timely manner.
This is the 100% gotcha rate.
Thank you!
Thank you for this super chat!
If Jack Jesus himself asked you to do the Jesus combo, would that count as Jesus asking?
I don't think...
I don't think he'll ask for it.
Thank you for this super chat!
Thank you!
Bro, that meant...
I don't think he'll ask for it, guys.
Um...
I know a lot of people are like, When will you play the horse game, Toki?
If I ever...
You have to bribe me to play the horse game, guys.
Literally, okay...
Literally, um...
I watched a little bit...
Cause like...
This morning...
Cause apparently, Littlewig was hosting a tournament or some shit.
And, um...
And I was curious...
Okay...
Like...
Uh...
The actual, like...
The part where...
I felt like the part where it gets exciting...
Was when they have...
They actually start racing.
But that was, like...
1%...
Of, like...
99% of the rest of...
There was so much reading!
There was...
Just skip it.
It'll be fine.
Don't worry.
Just ignore this horse game.
I want my sakura after Elder Ring.
So you're saying there's a chat.
Thank you for the Akka soup.
Thank you.
Subscribe to play the horse game.
Scythe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's plenty of options to skip.
And then they were like... Oh my god.
Like... Oh, I was just... I was... Okay, I will say the interesting parts about the horse game were not even like the actual game itself.
But the fact that they were like, you know, based off of the real horses.
And like... Like I got into the rabbit hole.
Um... Uh...
I got into the rabbit hole of reading the actual like... Um...
The actual like... Uh... History behind the real horses themselves.
So you know how like how everybody is like in love with Gold Ship?
Or whatever?
Um...
Because of like her quirkiness and everything?
And apparently the horse in real life was also like...
By the way, he's still alive, by the way.
Some of these horses are still alive.
But the... What's her name?
The Haru?
Whatever her name is.
The pink hair girl?
Or like people were like... Um...
I never because... Give up because...
She never gave... Because she never gave up on us too.
Um... She's a grandma right now.
So... I think like... Um...
Um... She's apparently like... Uh... A grandma right now.
Um...
Because like... I think she's like... What?
20...
Uh... She's like 28 or something.
And... Uh... Horse life expectancy is like 30 years old.
So like...
Tick tock.
Um...
Oh sorry.
That got real dark.
Um...
Yeah.
She's 29 and I'm crying.
Damn.
Oh my god.
Why did you tell me this?
Um...
That was harsh.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
So...
Okay.
Um...
So gold ship.
I thought it was...
Really interesting.
Like her... Um...
His lore.
Um...
And... Oh yeah.
The saddest part.
By the way.
I'll make you guys more sad.
But...
The saddest part about Haru...
Is that...
They never let...
Let them have kids.
Or him.
Right?
The actual horse is a guy.
But...
Um...
Haru...
Was never allowed to have kids.
After retirement.
So like...
They had no bitches.
So...
Uh...
Why did he give me three fucking rats?
Okay.
Um...
Yeah.
So like...
Literally...
There's no descendants.
Oh her.
Sorry.
She...
She was not allowed...
To have...
She...
Well they never like...
Let her have kids.
So...
Zero wins.
I...
Cause like...
You know...
Um...
Cause that's...
What I need to say.
No.
Sorry.
Your horse waifu is...
Actually...
Um...
Actually a woman.
But yeah.
Uh...
She wasn't...
She wasn't like...
Allowed to have any kids.
Um...
So like...
The bloodline ends with her.
Unfortunately.
Um...
Uh...
Excuse me.
It's one win and 113 noses now.
But who is a...
Who is a woman?
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
When I said leave room for Jesus.
I didn't mean leave this giant asshole.
In the middle.
Anyway.
As I was saying.
Okay.
We definitely lost that.
Um...
But...
Goldship is actually a man.
Um...
And like...
He's apparently...
Like...
Really...
Popular with the ladies.
And...
Basically...
Goldship...
After his retirement...
Like...
All the lady horses...
Would run up to him.
And be like...
Yeah...
Haha...
He was a playa...
He was actually an actual player.
Like, you... I was reading a thread about... Yeah, he's a parent.
He has insane riz.
And he has around, like, over 500 kids, by the way.
And, like, all the lady horses would, like, run up to him and be like, me next!
Me next!
That's my goat!
And, like, I thought this was, like, a little funny, fun fact.
Where, um... Um... During, like, he thought he was... Oh, shit, she disappeared.
She died.
Like, um... One of the, like... This was a funny, like, history tidbit.
But, basically, one time... Um... He thought he was going to the, uh... You know... The... Make a Kid Pro...
He thought he was going to meet the ladies one day.
Like, he was like, oh, yes, it's ladies' time, you know?
And then, um... And then, like, the trainers tricked him.
And it was actually to meet the fans.
So, it was, like, a meet and greet... Meet and greet program.
Um... And then, after... He pretended to be, like, okay with it.
It's like, oh, that's okay.
I love meeting fans.
And then, after the meet and greet was over, apparently, he threw a temper tantrum.
And was so fucking pissed off.
Because you're like, what do you... Where are my bitches at?
Like...
He had, like, a fucking crash show.
Right at... Right after, like, the meet and greet was over.
He's like, how can't... How dare you?
I was ready!
He, he, he, he, he, he, he...
Oh, I did.
Um...
And another, um...
Another fun fact, but apparently, like, he was, like, an incredibly smart horse.
So that, the average horse IQ is that of a three to five year old.
But, um...
Goldship was, like, the average IQ of a seven year old child.
So, like, that's scary.
That's...
I remember reading, like, um... like, from, like, you know, like, you know, like, little things, like, what is the worst age to take care of, um, to... when raising a child?
What are the scariest ages?
And it's, like, infant, and, like, and, like, around... and, like, it's, like, infants, because, like, you know, anything can happen when they're at an infant.
And then it's also, like, their most troublesome age is, like, around, like, seven years old.
Um, because, like, they're more curious, and they can walk, and, uh, they can walk and, like, actually start moving around.
Oh my god, I know, because I was a piece of shit when I was around that age.
And, um, and, um, when I think, like, when I was around that age, I tried to run away from home.
Um, because, like, okay, this is a pretty... I don't know if I told this story, but it's pretty dumb.
But basically, um, we were waiting at a Chinese restaurant for our seats with me, my parents, and my grandparents.
And I don't remember what my mom said, but it pissed me off.
I don't... I don't even... I don't even remember what my mom said, but I... it pissed me off.
And I was, like, I don't know, seven or eight.
And then, like, because it pissed me off, like, my grandpa was, like, watching me outside the Chinese restaurant while...
Uh, while we were, like, waiting for our number to be called to sit down, you know, because it was, like, a packed restaurant.
So, we were just waiting for our seat.
And then I got so mad, I, like, I just started running.
I just... I just... I started running.
And then I ran into, like, a suburban area.
And then my... uh, yeah, a full-on sprint.
And then my grandpa was just, like, trying to chase after me.
But obviously, like, I was a fucking little kid.
And my grandpa is a grandpa.
And...
I was, like, I'm gonna run away.
And, like, literally run away.
Um...
And then...
And then my grandpa was, like, chasing me.
And then I saw a police car in front of me.
And then I slowed down and started walking.
Because I was, like, just be...
Just...
Just be normal.
Like, act casual.
They don't know I'm actually...
I'm trying to run away.
And then literally, I...
I saw a police car in front of me.
Uh...
And then, like, with, like, the police dog, like, peeking out of the window.
I was, like, just be normal.
And my grandpa was, like, so far behind, by the way.
He was so fucking far.
I looked behind me.
He was so far away.
He was not gonna make it.
He was...
And then I just was, like, walking as if nothing weird was going on.
And the moment the car was, like, out of view, I started running again.
We got...
We got a runner.
Eventually, like...
Eventually, I was, like...
Um...
I don't know why.
I just...
I stopped running.
I was, like, you know what?
I'm tired.
And then, like, I let my grandpa catch up to me.
Uh...
Eventually, I got tired.
And I just let...
I just let him catch up.
I don't remember what that was.
Is that, like, the chonky goon?
I'm not angry anymore.
I told you guys.
I was actually...
I was a little shit.
Um...
I was...
I was such a little shit back then.
Oh, you stinky rat.
That's right.
Stinkiest.
Bum, bum, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Oh, it was...
Oh, nice!
Chonky.
Chonky, dad.
Back then?
Now I'm reformed, guys.
I'm a good person.
Did you see that again with a straight face?
I am a good person now.
Chonky, have you seen the long, wild old umbrella bird?
Wait, what's that?
Thank you for the super chat.
Uh, Hiro.
Thank you.
Seijin, thank you for the super sticker.
Ozni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A piece of shit.
Only around that age?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Let's see... Oh, I missed the last super chat.
Give me a sec.
I'm looking back.
Claps, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, is there a flood in Texas?
I hope everybody's okay.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki won't play the horse game because she's scared of making a Google Doki for threatening the horse girl with a Google glue factor.
I won't even be the first one.
But yeah, you'll have to, like, bribe me to play the horse game.
I feel like... I just, like...
I know it's, like, super popular right now.
Like, everybody's playing it, even, like, the normies and stuff.
Like, it's actually traveled outside of the normies...
Like, outside of the normal, like, intended audience.
I mean, like, of course it would.
Because it has... it's about gambling.
Like...
Yeah, it's literally... it's mainstream right now.
Like, I mean, but of course it would.
It's literally, like, legal gambling.
So I'm not...
I'm... I'm not surprised.
I'm not...
And, like, horse racing is actually...
Like, I don't know if it's still popular now in America.
But...
Like, we have...
Like, like I said, we.
I'm... I'm Canadian, by the way.
But horse racing is technically, like, really popular, right?
In America still.
It's just that they've never thought of the idea...
Like, there was never, like, an actual...
Uh...
Not really.
No.
The Kentucky Derby.
Yeah.
I know...
I know horse racing is a thing in America.
Because...
Oh, yeah.
And it's slowly getting banned, too.
I remember.
Because I was like, no.
Horse racing is still a thing.
Because we love to race...
Like...
I'm sorry.
I keep forgetting I'm not American.
Um...
They...
They love to...
I know you guys, too.
I know you guys forget I'm not American, too.
Uh...
And sometimes I forget, too.
But, like...
Americans...
They love to race random things.
I...
I don't know.
You guys know that.
If an animal can run...
They will make a race out of it.
Like...
What...
We have pig racing.
We have wiener dog racing.
We have dog racing.
We have...
Horse racing.
We...
We have...
Snail racing.
We have turtle racing.
There's...
Rat...
An animal can run.
An American will make a race out of...
Out of it.
So, of course, like...
Of course, I'm not surprised.
That...
The horse racing game.
When it finally have...
Uh...
When it's dad...
Have you guys never seen a...
Okay, I've...
No, I've...
I know I sent you...
I've sent, like...
Clips.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Make sure I do this before I...
Google it.
Just...
Just in case.
Alright.
Wiener...
Wiener dog.
I know I've linked it to you guys several times.
Alright.
What a race!
Alright, let's watch Wiener dog racing right now.
I...
It's the third annual...
All right, here we go.
Let's watch it.
It's only three minutes long.
What a race, guys!
All right, let's see.
That's fine.
All right.
Where is it?
I'm ready for my wiener dog races.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
There we go.
Okay, let me watch this wiener dog race.
This is very important to my stream.
This is very important.
There we go.
Houston, Texas, wiener dog races.
This is five years ago.
In lane one, Luna.
It's time to gamble!
All right.
Peanut.
In lane four, Jack.
Jack.
And Lady is in lane five.
All right, before we... All right.
Money all... All right, let's bet.
Who will win?
I only have four options, so I'm just going to add, like, four.
One, two, three, four.
Sorry, lady.
You didn't make the cut.
You didn't make the cut, lady.
All right.
That Houston, Texas wiener dog races.
On your mark, get set, go.
Oh, my God.
Wait, which one was that?
Sure.
Bro.
What?
Look at those wieners rhyme.
Woo!
Peanut!
Great job, Doxies.
There he is.
Yeah.
Congratulations to Frederick Footlong.
You're advancing to the finals.
Frederick Footlong.
We'll keep the same pull.
Look at all those weenies.
Let's reset for Heat 2.
All right.
Heat 2, guys.
Let's Heat 2.
All right.
Here we go.
It's Heat 2.
My money's off.
God.
All right.
Dogs.
I'm just going to... Two, three, four.
All right.
Wait.
What?
What has performance enhancers?
Get him out of here.
It's Cooper.
Wait.
There's no three.
And Limo is in lane five.
If you voted three.
Come on.
Who is it?
Wait.
Five is old.
Who let this grandpa race?
Go.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
He's so fast.
Go, go winners.
Go.
Han Solo doesn't need a Millennium Falcon.
He's on to the finals.
Oh, my God.
His name is Han Solo?
In the finals, we have Frederick Footlong versus Han Solo.
Oh, my God.
It's the final match.
All right.
The final match, guys.
He's going to win this.
All right.
Start a poll.
Finals.
Han Solo versus Footlong.
Bro, okay.
Not going to lie.
I think Han Solo is going to win.
That dog was fucking zooming.
Han Solo is the brown wiener dog.
Han Solo all the way.
It's a clash of the absolute titans.
The winner of this race will be crowned the winner of the 2019 Wiener Dog Races champion.
Oh, my God.
The wiener dog champion.
Look at him go.
On your mark, get set, go.
He's looking at him.
He's like, on your left, grandpa.
He may be short on legs, but he's long on heart and long on speed today.
Bro, he looked at him, the B.M.
Congratulations.
You are the 2019 Wiener Dog champion.
The fucking B.M.
He looked at him before he zoomed.
He's walking away a wiener.
Woo, Han Solo.
Wait, I need to see that.
Give me that in slow-mo.
I need to see that in slow-mo, guys.
Look at him.
Oh, my.
Look right here.
Right here.
Look at this.
In the slow-mo replay.
Look at him.
Look at that B.M.
On your right, grandpa.
He may be short on legs.
The disrespect.
He did the Luigi stare.
Dustin, that's my goat right there.
Not even close.
But like I said, like, I told you guys, I'm not surprised that this blew up.
The horse king blew up in the normie sphere.
All Americans love is just watching, just watching, like, animals race each other.
Oh, my.
Here's another one.
I ordered 200 handforged.
Okay, that's an ad.
He ordered 200.
What?
He ordered 200 knives.
That's his ad.
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is an...
Okay, this is an actual professional wiener dog race.
Look at this.
The wiener dog...
Up for heat.
Number one.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I still have, like, slow-mo on.
Like, look at this racetrack.
Number one is Luna.
Ooh, Luna.
Luna.
Good luck, Luna and Shelby Ralston.
Number two.
Oh, forget that.
That's my new O-sheet.
Luca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
The pros.
This is where the pros go.
What was it called in the Uma game?
This is a three-legged wiener dog.
Oh, my God.
Named Ringo.
You go, Ringo.
You don't need...
Ringo with three legs.
Don't doubt him.
You go, Ringo.
Number four.
You got this.
Mr. Boss Longbody.
Ringo, my God.
And number five.
Number five.
This is Rusty.
Oh, my God.
He's extra chunky.
Yeah, Rusty.
Yay, Rusty.
Yeah, three legs.
He's less the way to slow him down.
That's true.
Where's Winnie?
Oh, my God.
Wait, he's...
Look how buff Winnie is.
That's a fucking muscle.
This one goes by the name of Opus.
Oh, he's cute.
He's a...
My man Otis.
My man.
My...
Yo.
That...
Bro.
My dog is missing a fucking leg.
This is not me.
Look at that.
Bro, she's running in that dress?
Bro, what about Aerodynamic?
It's gonna slow you down, Winston.
And number nine is Vinnie.
Oh, wait.
They all have dresses.
Never mind.
They all...
Rounding out heat number one.
They all have little dresses.
Never mind.
It's fair.
She is Millie.
Hello, Millie.
Oh, she's old.
Line up for heat number one.
All right.
Are they racing?
Are they...
When does the race start?
Okay, we're gonna skip to the races now.
And now have a line up for heat number two.
We don't care about heat two.
Oh my god.
Bro, what?
This is where they're running.
Holy...
This is so professional.
She's the dog from Cars 1.
There's like 10 dogs or something.
Oh, they're ready.
They're fucking ready, ready.
That's a pro horse, bro.
This is professional right there.
One dog's trying to walk away.
I see you.
Ladies and gentlemen.
The wieners are in their spots.
Oh, they're there.
Go!
Here come the wieners.
They shoot out of there straight and strong.
Mr. Boss Longbody gallops along nicely.
Car crash!
Oh my god, she's so fast!
That is one fast wiener!
Oh my god!
That was so...
The momentum!
Top three advanced!
They're just like, oh, we're out here now.
These precious little puppies.
Look at them go.
Number eight, Winston.
Look at this.
Don't wait, what?
Stop, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
You guys gotta see this.
You guys gotta see it.
We got distracted.
Wait, wait, wait, okay.
Okay, watch this.
It's scary!
Wait, what the fuck happened?
Are you right here?
Let's just say this is the monster.
What are you doing?
Oh my god!
Holy cow, what a fast wiener.
That chat the final is these lots.
Just there for a good time.
Luna, let's go, Luna!
Pass away!
Wasn't she the one with the fucking muscles?
Okay, bro, look at that, look at that muscle.
Bro, no, that was the dog.
That was buff as hell.
Bro, she's jacked.
Did you see those muscles there?
That shit was jacked.
All right, let's watch the second race.
We don't know who they are, but they seem really cute.
Luna is jacked as hell.
Wait, he's mixed.
Excuse me.
I thought this was a wiener dog only.
That's not a full purebred wiener.
Where's your certificate?
I need to see your birth certificate.
Imposter!
I wrecked...
Oh, shit!
You can't...
That's a weenie that's mixed up with a chihuahua.
That's a chihuahua weenie.
I need number two.
Weenie papers!
Instruction's unclear.
Oliver, no!
Whoa!
Run!
It's so fast!
Oh!
She got it!
Fluffy wiener is so...
I mean, they're just out...
So the wienies just one of...
Hey, Oliver, you silly!
What happened?
He's getting us!
Look at Oliver, this fluffy little wiener, sir!
What's he eating?
What is Oliver eating?
And they're fudgey up for a sunday stroll.
Oliver, what did you eat?
We'll take a look at the video here.
He's eating, bro!
Oliver is a special one.
He's very special.
Oliver came out and had no desire to run.
But now, here's Jasmine!
Bro, it's just...
He's a special little dog, okay?
He went and wrapped backwards!
We'll see y'all on Labor Day!
What is this slow-mo for?
Oh, right here.
Holy shit!
What?
That's not a wiener!
I didn't see his papers!
What the fuck?
Now that's a purebred wiener, though!
That's right!
Show that half-read what's it about!
I recognize my wienies!
Don't you stop!
That's a joke!
DNA, check that dog right now!
Um, excuse me!
It says wiener dog races!
This is Ola!
Oh, shit.
Safeway!
Hey, well...
Look at the Safeway!
We got ads!
Um...
All right.
Okay, now we watch...
I wanted to show you guys this.
Look at this.
Known as the Oval.
This will completely change the sport we know it.
The Oval Circus.
The League.
Watch!
Look at this!
This is the League of Pigs.
There is an actual league.
There's a pig league right now.
Let him go.
I actually watched pig races, like, in real life.
There's like a fair here in my city.
And, like, they like to... during the summer, they like...
Season 10?!
What do you mean season 10?!
But, um...
During...
During, like, summer, they would host, like, pig races and stuff.
And I've seen one.
Yeah, they love... yeah, county fairs love doing these things.
All right, we don't care about this.
I'm here for the races.
All right, here we go.
The Henry Cup?!
Piggy S'mores!
All right, race one.
This does not look promising as Piggy S'mores is on top of the box.
And things go from bad to worse as Hoshi decides he's gonna improvise rather than get on...
Oh my god, he's off track!
Hoshi is off track!
How is he gonna get back in?!
But she is receiving pressure from Ginger, and now Piggy S'mores is attacking on the inside.
And as they go around the tree, Piggy S'mores has stolen the lead off Bear.
Bear now struggling to fend off Ginger and Piggy S'mores.
Piggy S'mores must get the win, surely, but Ginger's attacking for second.
Oh my god, Ginger's so close!
You can see already, it's very difficult to get a clear view of the finish line from the main camera.
The loser becomes S'mores.
Where would I get my pig girl races?!
Why are we stopping at horse girls?!
Make all the animals!
I want spinoffs!
I want my spinoff games!
I yet to spread that the large delay for Hoshi and receiving food is all the convincing he'll need to stay in trouble.
I want my puta musume!
Pig racing is serious business!
And that meant that pigs were able to get much further into the wood than they were last season.
A fact that certainly not lost on the five pigs.
I'm making it all!
And they almost instantly adapted to foraging.
There's a pig racing game I'm all in!
I'm in it!
Piggy S'mores!
Can we watch snail races next?!
Gary, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Let's do it.
Let's look at the next one.
What the life of a pig actually looks like.
Oh, race two!
The first downhill race of the oval track has Hoshi and Bear leading at Hoshi pokes his nose in front.
And there's a good corner there.
But Piggy S'mores does an exceptional corner there as he overtakes Peppa and now he overtakes Ginger.
Oh my god, you go, Piggy S'mores!
Go, Piggy S'mores!
Come on!
Oh my god, he's ketchup!
He's hitting his ult!
He's ulting!
Oh!
Oh, it was a close race!
Yo, there's a dog swimming...
Wait, there's a dog swimming race?!
Alright, guys, we're just...
Alright.
Dog swimming race.
Okay, I...
This I gotta see.
I...
What the...
There's no way...
This has to be...
Okay, that's AI.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say...
That has...
There is...
Incredible Dog Diving National Championship.
Alright.
Alright, what is this?
Karina Farms in the National Championship Finals.
And right there, you're looking at the best in the business in diving dogs.
Look, we're talking about racing, right?
This is on topic!
Incredible dog challenge record holders, but this stacked field is finally...
This is...
This is priority.
They're in the lead with a 34...
I didn't know about this dog diving.
any shit?
Oh my god!
This is just 1.8 million views?
I have not heard about this.
What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
Bro, this is like the long jumper in the water.
Oh my god, look at him go, he's flying!
This is like the... what was it called?
The key and peel sketch?
With the football graphics.
The air tie.
Wow!
The propeller tail!
The dog actual blast.
Oh my god, look at him!
Oh my god, it's a helicopter tail!
Oh, the slow mode!
Holy shit, the slow mode!
If I keep slow mode on his face, he's actually using his tail for more air time.
That's crazy.
The strats are insane.
When his dad is never jumping again, guys.
Roy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not after the accident.
Oh, he got it though!
Oh my god, the best of the best, guys.
With 32 feet, Shleen, that's unheard of that 32 feet is in fifth place this year.
Wait, 32 feet?
Who's first?
It's 50 feet long?
Why?
Okay, we're going to the most play.
Clearly, that guy.
We gotta see the winner.
They won our Dallas-Fort Worth Central Regionals earning a spot here to the National Championship Finals.
It was so close, guys.
It was so... alright, this is apparently the most viewed.
We have been coming to the Purina Incredible Dog Tour.
Oh my god, it's American Idol, like, sad story time.
And it is the highlight of our year.
The biggest jump for Sounders.
What the fuck?
I think he might have just broken that.
36 feet.
A brand new world record.
Where is he?
What?
He's turned eight this year, so...
Bro, he's eight?
I see the dogs jumping.
There's some great dogs.
He's got some puppies of his and some...
Bro, how old is that in, like, human age?
And, uh, so I fully expect to be beaten by one of those.
Incognito, he's two years old.
He's gonna be three in December.
And he is a Sounders grandson.
You know, it's really fun to...
Oh my god, he's gonna...
He's gonna, like, um...
Take...
You're going down, old man.
I'm gonna overtake your legacy.
Bro, that guy is 56 and he's still doing it.
LeBron, watch out.
Up and coming.
The future is now, old man.
He does it for the love of the game.
He has the potential to jump as far as Sounders for sure.
Um, whether or not we'll see that.
Um, we'll just have to wait and see.
I wanna see him jump!
Great, but it's really about the experience here.
It's just about...
Time to retire, Grandpa.
It's like a beautiful facility.
And everybody does everything to make sure everything is so...
Safe and wonderful, then, for them.
And giving us a bigger pool.
Alright, here we go.
A bigger pool!
Alright!
Alright, Grandpa!
Show us how it's done!
Oh, he's ready.
He's ready.
He's like...
This is it.
I grew up in this sport, kid.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
30...
Okay, 34 is pretty good.
For an old man.
30 feet 11 inches.
Wait, he's first?!
Oh my god.
He's still first!
And he's 54 years old!
Grandpa still got it.
Ha ha ha!
Grandpa still got it!
He's literally LeBron, Tom and Tom, I'm Brady.
Oh, it's the child.
Oh, it's the child's turn.
He's like, don't wait, dad.
I'll show you.
He's not retiring anytime soon, kid.
Oh.
Keep training, kid.
Keep training.
The kid's got heart, though.
The kid's got heart.
We were so off topic.
Put him in the range, kid.
Your old man still has years in him.
Not rubbing it in his face, but it really is.
Bronny James.
He went down a tricky rabbit hole.
It's like me showing you guys.
Look at the video on my phone right now.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure this stream is going to be demonetized by the pig leagues.
The pig leagues are going to get me.
I think it was a good time to call it here.
I'm going to...
You know what?
I have some time, though.
Before we do call it...
Let's bring back something.
Let's bring it back.
It's super chat reading time!
Yay!
Oh my gosh, it's been so long.
I've not done super chat reading.
But that was fun.
I had...
The pig leagues.
They're going to get me.
Because I watched their...
I watched their videos without permission.
All right, let me put up the...
Donation reading time.
God, it's been so long.
It's been so long since we've done this.
All right, let's put that chat back, too.
But this was fun.
I had a fun time hanging out with everybody today.
Let's see.
For those who don't know, by the way, my merch is out right now.
So yeah!
Buy my merch!
It really means a lot.
I'm not sure when...
If there is going to be a limited order period for any of them yet.
But they'll let me know later on.
Especially for the birthday merch.
Most likely.
Maybe...
I don't know.
I don't know yet.
So yeah!
Please, it's a great way to support me.
Like I said, other ways to support...
Merch is another great way to support me.
So yeah!
And there's a lot of really cool stuff there for you to try.
All right, enough show time.
Now it's super chat reading time.
Because I don't know which one I haven't read yet.
Uh...
Orbiton!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Next time you play fetch with dad in a big field, motivate him with the glue factory!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Dogs don't...
Dogs don't make good glue, guys.
Luca, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
VTuber move.
I'm trying to watch the dogs.
Shush VTubers.
I'm trying to bet on these dogs right now.
Oh no.
I need to refresh my super chat stuff so I can see the super chat.
All right, where was I in super chat reading?
Marshall and NCG!
Okay, you both said the same thing but Haru actually won a race recently and got one win post retirement.
Good for her.
Yeah, I saw that too.
Like I said, I think the most interesting part about the horse racing game was just a real actual lore from the actual horses themselves.
So, like, that's what was interesting.
Like, not the actual horse girls.
I'm sorry.
I think the real Laura was, like, much more, like, um, cool.
Like, more cool to read about.
Yeah.
But it was nice to see, like, the attention to detail and stuff.
Um, I heard, like, if you go to Japan, uh, go to Japan, there's, like, several restaurants and, like, bars and stuff that are, like, dedicated to, like, specific horses.
Like, apparently, there is, like, a huge horse fandom.
Before, like, the horse girl game ever came out, um, the horses already had their own fandoms and stuff.
So, like, um, they just, like, you know, it was, like, um, it was just, like, another...
It was a big thing before the game even came out in general.
Yeah, it's massive in Japan.
And apparently, like, I think, you know, it's getting banned in America because, like, um, um, animal rights is not great.
When it comes to horse racing, honey, um, the animal rights in America for horse racing is not great.
Uh, so, that's why it's slowly getting banned in America.
So, that's why I say I'm not surprised.
Um, I'm not surprised that, like, um, um, that it's blowing up in the normie sphere.
Um, in America, only because, like, you know, it's a legal way to...
It's more legal.
To replicate the feeling of horse racing.
Uh, Raven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, let's see.
What else I'm saying is...
Uh...
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Goldship's rider didn't pray for him to win.
He prayed for him to be normal.
Um, I know, like, dog racing is also, like...
Like, the greyhound racing is also slowly, like, um, getting banned and, like, being, like, uh...
Like, slowly getting banned and not being as popular anymore because of, like, the rules and laws when it comes to, like, breeding for greyhounds for it as well.
Um, but, like, wiener dog racing is fine because it's just, like, the fuck around, you know?
It's...
Wiener dog racing is fine.
Yeah, greyhounds are, like, not treated the best, too.
Yeah, they're fucking crazy fast.
Usni!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, piece of shit.
Only around that age?
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Texas is okay.
They have Hank Hill and his propane.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah, wiener dog racing is perhaps not the most competitive.
What of all?
Oh, racing.
It's probably...
Probably not that competitive.
But when we...
I mean, we just...
We just...
They just love racing.
I don't know.
Racing is just, like, in American's blood.
They just want to know.
They just want...
I don't know.
It's just, like...
There's just something primal about being the fastest.
You know, like, in recess, kids would be like, I bet I'm faster than you.
There's just...
There's just something primal about it.
Hell yeah, brother.
And gambling.
The love of gambling and racing together.
We have to know.
Who is the fastest?
If it wasn't fucked up, I bet you...
I bet you...
If, like, there were no laws stopping it...
There's no laws...
In...
In Pokemon, Batman.
Okay, if there's no laws to stop it...
I bet you America would have invented cheetah racing.
I...
If there wasn't any laws...
Cheetah racing would be 100% a thing.
Um...
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You say that like normal...
But that sounds sick, though!
Guys!
Cheetahs are sort of almost endangered.
Dude!
Bro!
We had a baby fight club in America!
Oh my god!
So many fucked up things happened in America!
Bro, what the fuck!
There was a fucking underground baby fight club in America, guys!
I talked about it before on a collab.
I don't remember which collab, but...
Um...
A daycare got what, um...
There was a daycare in America where they were running an illegal baby fight club where people were betting on babies and stuff.
And then they were only found up...
Like, found up because the parents, when they got their babies back, they're like, Why are there bruises and stuff on my baby?
And then the daycare players...
The daycare players...
The daycare owners were like, Oh yeah, no, your baby just fell down and just had like a bruise.
Like, just...
They just fell down and like, you know, hurt...
Like, um...
Got too rough when they were playing.
Um...
But yeah, no, that shit was crazy.
You say that like legal baby fight clubs are a thing.
Never mind, I was joking.
Don't bring it back.
Um...
Uh...
Black...
Black talent.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
They did do it.
They tried doing cheetah racing back in the 50s.
There's no way that's...
Oh my god.
I was like, oh my god.
What would be funny?
But like, I'm pretty sure.
Like, cheetah racing...
Uh...
History.
There's no way.
There's no way they actually...
Real cheetah...
Cheetah animal racing.
It gives me a car.
12 cheetahs arrived from Kenya in December 1936.
Alright.
In December 1936, they bought 12 cheetahs from Kenya to fucking host the goddamn race.
That's...
Oh my god.
He planned to stage races featuring both greyhounds and cheetahs.
That is a man with a dream.
Right there.
Um...
Journalists and politicians were concerned about the treatment of the dogs and the cheetahs.
Yeah.
No.
Oh shit.
Bro.
Everyone...
They...
This...
Okay.
Um...
This is crazy.
Although, Dower assured everyone that cheetahs were both trainable and docile.
This, despite a few attacks that led to two cheetahs being put down.
Guys, don't worry guys.
They're so trainable.
We do have to put down two cheetahs though.
But don't worry.
It'll be okay.
Bro.
Okay.
Oh.
We know now that cheetahs are indeed faster than...
Oh wait.
They're trying to see which one's faster.
The cheetah or...
Um...
Uh...
Oh.
Apparently ended because of World War II.
Okay.
That...
You know what?
I feel like...
Yeah.
There's much...
There's priorities here.
Because of World War II.
We managed...
We managed to stop cheetah racing.
Um...
Oh my...
That tracks.
Yeah.
Uh...
Nuka.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's what...
That's what ended it!
Not because of unhumane.
It was...
Anything else could have stopped it.
You know?
Like animal rights.
But no.
It's just because they just didn't have enough time because of World War II.
Uh...
Luka.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
You're Canadian but you haven't apologized once.
Johnny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got five on number three.
Let's go!
Gary.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Five.
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
Droom, are youczy me in the super chat?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to figure out where I am at...
..in my super chat.
Gladstone.
I'm thinking about in the super chat.
Thank you.
Love how the Doki Suica stream turns out to be the React stream in disguise.
Absolute City Sinema.
Peak Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is like...
Like, real life can never...
Can ever replace the anime version.
Unless the only way the anime version can be superior to the real-life scenario is when we get...
All I want in life is...
Where is it?
I need my pig racing.
That would be true.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blake, thank you for the super chat.
Ostrich racing when...
I'm pretty sure they do have it.
I'm pretty sure that exists.
Unfortunately, the Americans didn't invent...
Oh my... Wait!
It's from the same park!
Wait, is this the same park?
Okay, we're back.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god, this is like...
Wait...
Okay, no, no.
Remember the fucking Canterbury Park?
It's the same one...
Before ostriches!
Oh my god!
Yeah, it is!
It's the same one before ostriches!
There's chalkies on it!
What the... There's no way that's real!
There's no...
AI?
No way!
It's real!
It's not even AI!
It's...
It's like leaning back and like...
Go back in there!
It is...
It's not even...
It's 2024!
I can't see this again!
Luca, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, bro!
He's holding on!
We won't race anything!
This is 2024!
Don't let your dreams be dreams guys!
It's the same park where they held the wiener!
Okay!
The Minnesota Horse Race Track hosted ostrich, camel, and zebra racing!
Wait!
Zebra racing?
Alright.
Ostrich racing is true cinema.
Blake, thank you for the super chat.
Alexander Camelton!
Here comes the Sheik and Hubert Humphrey by Hamilton!
Let's go!
Let's go, Alexander Camelton!
I don't think that's zebras.
He was pouring for this!
Alright, what's the replay like?
Donald Hump, funny, went to the right out of the gate.
Look at the Sheik.
Raphael Mojica Jr. Riding that camel for everything he has.
But it's Delgado and Alexander Camelton!
Oh my god!
The leading quarter horse rider just won a quarter horse like this.
Wait.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Here we go.
And did it go!
He doesn't care!
He'll keep on going!
He needs no rider!
Bird, bird, bird, bird is the word!
They're so cute!
Okay, I need to see the zebra!
Hi, they're sort of like horses.
But like- Ooh, wait.
We don't need plumbing help, guys.
We- Let's- We're fine.
Excuse me, I'm here for my zebra races right now.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, I don't think they're...
Oh my god, Jay-Z is going crazy!
They're giving up!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they still kept the jockey!
He won!
The remaining jockey wins!
He tried to run into the circle to eat the children!
That's so fucked up!
He comes out running this town.
Then it's Zebron James.
But in the NBA Finals, he quits.
Frankie Johnson down.
Now Jay-Z wants to eat children.
Shepard gets into Jay-Z.
He's going to win the race easily.
Wait, here comes Zebron James.
Oh wait, he quit again.
And now Shepard tries to cross the line and doesn't.
And Justine Klaver wins.
Oh, he didn't cross the line!
He stopped that right there!
Here come the zebras into the winner's circle.
I passed this place on my way to the...
Ozzy!
Are you telling me?
You missed out on cameras!
Camels!
Zebra!
And ostrich racing!
I can't believe it!
You were so close to greatness!
And you didn't even go!
I...
You can...
You could have seen these lines!
There it is again!
I did!
I hate myself!
But the zebra said no!
And Miss...
Miss Klaver just comes cruising in right now!
Now Zebron James is going to win!
Did I really through them?
And here comes Miss Klaver with the pink helmet!
Look at that!
Brilliant camera work by the team!
He's like, fuck you!
And Miss Klaver wins!
Spectacular!
Pictures!
What is this?
Oh, now it's the real horse racing!
Now...
We don't care about that!
We're here for the real content!
Zebra racing is the real content!
Alright!
Okay!
JR!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Who cares about the horses?
After finding out there's zebra racing?
If you ever mind about animation or using your likeness?
We're recently getting back into 3D animation!
And I have a bunch of ideas!
Some including you and the sloppy sisters!
Yes!
I don't mind at all!
Um, I love fan content!
So if you guys want to make any fan content of me, animation game wise or whatever, it's free to- as long as you don't make profit off like, you know, like, um, obviously if you guys want to put like ads or whatever, like monetization ads on your videos,
that's fine with me!
But as long as you don't like, um, what's it called?
Like, mass-produced stuff like that, that's where like, I'm like, oh, maybe not, you know?
But no, it's fine!
It's fine!
If you want to put like ad monetization, it's fine too!
Um, I'm fine with that!
Um, Luke!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh, uh, uh, my favorite thing was man versus beast!
I was so sad they only made two episodes!
Orangutan versus sumo wrestler tug of war!
That was awesome!
Wait!
That was real!
That sounds sick!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
JL!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
My kamioshi is just like me, for real, for real!
Gets sidetracked by any kind of animal videos!
Okay, but it was like, they were sick animal videos though!
I was trying to prove that point!
Okay!
This was better than any anime game!
This was...
This was so much better!
Solid Snake!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
If you think of something silly, humans probably may try it!
We act on a wouldn't it be funny principle!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, true!
I stopped playing the watch!
Luca!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god!
That's you!
Um, Blake!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Ostrich Racing!
True Cinema!
Adam!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm sorry, Doki!
I had nice shifts when you had your bday stream!
And I missed it completely!
Wishing you everything the best!
Love you!
You're awesome!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's alright!
It's okay, as long as you're here to support me and hang out with me, that's all that matters.
Adam.
Uh, YOU're wraith to the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
While on the topic of weird racing sports, there's a wife-carrying competition.
It's in fact, A REAL thing now.
There's a lot of really fucking weird competitions in sports.
I know there's one!
Whererr, um, also thinking of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's one that's like a traditional competition where you just throw a giant piece of log.
It's like whoever... and you have to like hold it upright too.
Like the piece of log is like facing up in the air.
And it's like whoever can throw it the furthest.
And it's like a traditional...
It's like a traditional like... I think like... is it Irish?
Or is it Scottish?
I don't remember.
Is it the caber toss?
Oh, yeah.
And then there's the cheese wheel.
I know about the cheese wheel from the meal pet scheme.
But yeah, I think it was one or the... it's one or the other.
Um, and there's one where you have to chase the cheese...
Um, people have to chase the cheese down a hill.
And that's also like an old time competition.
Uh...
Amphibian, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Alright!
I think that's all the super chats today!
Yay!
We did our first super chat reading after so long!
I miss doing these.
But now that, you know, I'm less busy now.
I don't have to worry about like the birthday prep stuff and everything.
Um, things are like...
The load is lighting up a lot more.
I can finally hang out and talk to you guys.
I don't have to worry about maintaining my voice anymore for like singing or anything.
So I'm very happy to be able to do the super chat reading with you guys again.
Yeah!
Anyway guys, I'm gonna head off now.
I'm gonna rest before my next stream.
Um, most lately I might push the stream...
Actually, no.
I'll still keep it at 5pm.
Um...
But at 5pm PST, I will have my last Mecha Break stream, um, on Twitch.
Uh, for Twitch drops.
So if you guys haven't got your Twitch drops yet, where you can be a cat girl.
Um...
Today is the last day.
And I'll be doing two hours of that.
Um, but yes.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!